okay okay I see thanks for coming in
this is the Jenna Julian podcast I had
one Julia's Oh her guest this week is
Brett our friend Brett he's been on
before everyone say hi to Brett Brett
you say hi everyone hi everyone yeah we
thought we'd have him back on he was on
like a couple months ago it was a while
ago it was it was early on yeah it was
really early on beside for something
like that yeah Brett's still the only
guest we've ever had in the podcast KITT
KITT was on oh that's right we do need
to be better we need to get more guests
on because when we started this podcast
I did like get excited that we were
gonna get to sort of interview and talk
to people cuz that's kind of like what I
like to do so we'll be better about that
we shall lay on a tray we shall in
trying to improve I'm I like all the way
down yeah a little bit yeah
okay yeah it sounds good all that
matters in life is if you sound good if
you have good audio that's vain okay so
for today's podcast requested by no one
at all I just decided that it would be
fun uh I'm sure many of you know that I
have a master's degree in sports
psychology and counseling now mind you I
graduated in 2009 so it's been a hot
minute since I've been opening up my DSM
over here I promise you say what a DSM
is do son basically is the criteria for
diagnosing someone with a mental
disorder and before anyone gets the
wrong idea
let me just make a sappy for word about
mental illness and mental health on
plague Island Thanks it's not sad I'll
still play the violin okay how about
some drums okay you play the drums I'll
play the violin but
we're just faking right mental illness
is very very very real there's still
unfortunately in our culture a strong
stigma against people that suffer from
mental illnesses and disorders but
they're [ __ ] very real they're not a
choice they're very serious but there
are as many people know many many things
with like little ridiculous names or
whatever you know yeah
in your [ __ ] DSM or your psychology
book of your science book bla bla bla so
as a two-fold way to do this not that
I'm doing some giant like public service
here by bringing attention to mental
illness but I thought it would be fun to
play the game where it's like dictionary
the game dictionary when you look up a
word and everyone around you has to like
write down the silliest definition that
they can and then you pick them out but
hopefully I stayed away from like a lot
of the very very serious sad or you know
anything life-changing mental disorders
I tried to stay on the at least we could
laugh at some poop and peens that kind
of thing um not that those aren't
serious as well I feel like there's a
lot of opportunity for this to get taken
the wrong way so if you get it then
please get it okay and yeah we just
wanted to play a silly game because some
of the words sound kind of silly right
it's literally making fun of how the
words are spelled inside has nothing
further to do with anything right so but
then also I would like to read what it
actually is so then to educate you and
and us I don't know what these things
are when we completely guessed you can
educate us Jenna okay but I just want
everyone to just be on the same page of
what the goal is here we're gonna have
some silly laugh times but then I'm also
maybe gonna tell you a disorder that you
didn't know existed and that some people
out in the world are actually suffering
with and that is serious so please take
their responses as responses to the word
itself and not to the actual disorder
but hopefully you learn something and
hopefully we get some giggles in here
yeah yeah absolutely and you can do this
with like anything like any any set of
words or her name yeah science or
history textbook I'm sure you can
and we just happen to do this one
because jenna is a psychology masters
and she has this book here so we have it
at our disposal so we did this
beforehand so we wouldn't have to write
while we're on the podcast so we have
all of our answers ready right
so me and Brett are gonna she's gonna
name them off and me and Brett Brett and
I are gonna come up with all right so
and then we're gonna decide who wins
Yeah right
yeah we you gotta decide though I'm not
gonna go for Brett all right so the
first one when are we ready for the game
I think we're all winners here geez I
think you're the real winners you're the
real in your room okay okay so the first
one okay I don't even I think it Spica
the word is pronounced pike okay it's
about me I see a yes
all right like a we're going first what
what is FICA Hika Hika babies that blow
bubbles with their spit and snot at the
same time simultaneous fit and snot
bubble blowing by babies is what pi k is
so why can I ask a couple questions like
what would happen when they blow the
bubbles is the outside the bubble spit
or snot and then it's a spit on the
inside of the snots on the outside our
works no this was like a forum to get
spit bubbles from their mouths not
bubbles it just forms a giant beautiful
box you know you've seen babies do that
yeah all the time
I see weird spica that's like I mean
okay hmm all right we heard is okay
what's yours okay Hika don't read it a
little isn't it it just takes away I get
it um so Micah or as you you know
phonetically would say pika that's how
it's pronounced this condition forms
when a person has an uncontrollable
impulse to dress his salsa up as a girl
thus in the affecteds mind justifying li
changing the pico de gallo to the proper
feminine version pico de gallo Wow
oh man I'm so weird oh my god okay those
are two very different definitions of
Piko is everyone ready for what it
actually is yeah what is pike ah well
should I choose a winner first or should
I choose a winner after I read what it
is first you think so what do you think
I think if I read it and then you guys
know what it is then you could choose
her image yeah okay let's do it after so
pika is the persistent eating a non
nutrition non-nutritive like non
nutritional substances for a period of
at least one month the eating of non
nutrition so like people that like eat
cigarette butts right my strange
addiction like get these paper towels
they like so literally non dirty
breaker and they're compelled to eat
things mine has to do with food so okay
now that's that's very interesting I
didn't realize my winner is Julian yes I
think you did the word Micah as far as
better service yeah okay
that's fair I'll take it pika-pika
digging out the proper feminine version
then it would peak it would be pica de
gaia I gotta fix that so for anyways for
those of you that have watched my
strange addiction or like I don't
understand why that person doesn't just
stop eating their couch uh it's a it's a
disorder because because they can pika
because it's more complicated than this
more common okay what was their next one
next one Oh rumination disorder oh yeah
my turn
I switch off first okay so my definition
for rumination disorder is when a person
disassociates with their home country
every single time they enter a new room
effectively naming every new room a
nation a nation you already won that one
so shitty what do you got I wrote a
person obsessed with the behavior of a
room but I like obsessed with the
behavior because by the way it could be
said that I am suffering from rumination
disorder because I would follow a Roomba
around 4 so that's what a person does
they just like obsessively falling
around just like like they just they
talk to it they dress it up I've seen
rumbas that have stickers and decals and
things on we should dress her we should
hand Liza dab name it my Roomba wears
exhibit they sent far room like a strip
of LED lights on there oh my god he's
already a DJ it's gonna be such a party
think about that a robot going around
your house cleaning with lights on
playing the hottest new hits
yo DJ Robo what's hot sorry I would love
that
oh yeah no I was with a guy who's
golfing with on Sunday Scott he we were
just randomly in the car on the way home
and he was like do you guys have a
Roomba I was like oh my god we just got
what he's like we did - it's amazing
yeah uh so I guess it could be said that
you're you have a touch of the
rumination as well oh yeah big time I
suffer I suffer all the time from that
thanks to your dad fictional rumination
yeah my dad said to - yeah what's the
real difference the fictional those are
really strong fictional ruminations the
real rumination is repeated
regurgitation and reaching of food for a
period of at least one month but these
are also for like infancy childhood or
adolescence so it could just be a baby
that really just wants to eat his food
and then eat his food again so it has
nothing to do with nations so you're
telling me is nothing against nations
damn it
so you're saying it doesn't involve
nations America nope
all right I'm I you know I think I'm
just gonna give both you a point like
Jeff Chef Ramsay does okay that's good I
like that I like that executive call so
I'm winning two to one yeah okay okay
you make that choice because you're
basically Chef Ramsay here rumination
room a nation room a nation all right
next one
and cope rhesus and cope rhesus what do
you got my first yep an old person
working with a group of much younger
people is experiencing an caprices that
sounds like it could be damn real an old
person that is yeah you know that's
younger so you know like when you work
somewhere and like everyone's like you
know 20 or whatever and then there's the
one random like 45 year old yeah what
are you doing here
you know we don't have any TV so that's
a mental disorder
that's an cope rhesus and caprices is
whatever Brett wants it to be that's
true that is fictional no that's all of
these people are experiencing and
Caprice so who is more affected by
encompasses in the situation the young
people or the one old person well I kind
of see it kind of goes both ways
different symptoms for different oh okay
it's like it's like an all-encompassing
thing is it's an EM Caprice the same
thing yeah you know what I want to learn
more yeah because you know the old
person has to deal with being a loner
and not really understanding what the
young ya are talking about and then the
young people are like how do we include
the old person and then think about the
the volume of inner turmoil at the old
person who has to fight the battle of
well do I try to blend in and change who
I am or do I just stay strong and be the
outsider can lead the pika can lead a
rumination disorder yeah you may go yeah
go all right here we go n caprices this
disorder creates an alternate reality
where a person tries to communicate with
people via Capri Suns by walking around
stabbing people with a small yellow
straw and quietly whispering into it
they also do that cell phone thing with
Capri Sun packages you're on fire
Oh take my money [ __ ] take my money
you did that right with the MT Capri Sun
you stick this drawing it like it's this
like it's a cell phone antenna and you
fold it you know well what I used to do
with empty Capri Suns is below
back up so they look full oh yeah and
then try to give that [ __ ] to my friend
and I already drank that [ __ ] I had a
box of Capri Suns at work for a while at
word right yeah I haven't seen one of
those in years drinking a pre sign as an
adult is so like fulfilling sometimes
when you stab it to like aggressively
and it goes all the way through the
package yeah I've basically murdered
your Capri Sun I don't know who I was
talking to but we were saying that we
should get syringes and like fill them
with vodka and then shoot it recently I
was like a stroke of genius I'm sorry
people are you can just wear the Capri
Sun out no cuz the whole thing is that
you're drinking oh I see we're saying
yeah and then you just like funnel that
through this really having it in the in
the pouch is pretty easy pretty very
cool yeah it's like a flask but it's
cooler and it's a Capri Sun and it's
funny because I think it's drink I was
getting [ __ ] up on kids doing this
funny funny hue so what's the real
definition for that one and caprices is
the repeated passage of feces into
inappropriate places like clothing or
floors whether involuntary or
intentional and it usually happens after
the age of four or it needs to in order
to get diagnosed within caprices needs
to happen over the age of four because
before h4 that's normal behavior
I did I did know a young boy when I was
like babysitting age and he was obsessed
with putting his poop everywhere
especially on his spongebob he had a
giant like huge spongebob we think our
dogs to lay on the ground is a probably
loved to take his poop and he loved to
spread it on SpongeBob but it would just
you try to like clean his hands off and
it would just be in his fingernails
lemon and then you would clean it up
yeah he was just happy as a clam now he
would clean it up
that boy was just happy as a clam who
needs video games I got my own poo he
just loved his own poop you know and
caprices anyways I think Julian one that
right yeah I would
it was very magical thank you I was so
good thank you
I wanted a capri-sun now all right next
one
enuresis all right and ureases when a
person walks uncontrollably door to door
handing people half open Reese's
chocolates while saying these are yours
now because enuresis I apologize well so
I mine is the opposite of n CAPRISA so a
young person working with a group of
much older people see Brett you're on
the right track he's staying on thieves
repeated voiding of urine into bed or
clothes whether voluntary or
unintentional aren't so just to explain
like the way that like that makes sense
thought process cuz I was doing what you
have been doing all along which is
basically breaking up the work the work
into different pieces and so I saw it
anyway that's know is really well done I
met as much as I liked but telling
people that these are yours I'm gonna
give the point to break even before inna
oh you already read it yeah because he
he recognized the pattern and he made a
joke he believed he deserves that dub
I'll give him that dub thank you yeah
so what is 302 now preciate that beta
yeah you're still winning in two alright
so we have two more the next one isn't
really a definition though it's just
that the next one is a little bit
different so um it again I don't this is
the dsm-4 I think there's a dsm-5 at
this point but according to the DSM 4
there is caffeine intoxication with a
specific amount of caffeine it takes for
you to be technically intoxicated so I
asked them to write down what they
thought according to the DSM it would
take for you to be caffeine intoxicated
who wants to go first
I you know yeah I so I did it in
milligrams because I do know that
caffeine is measured that way and I kind
of thought about it well first of all
cat I mean I know that
you guys can drink caffeine [ __ ] all
of it all of it all day long and go to
sleep at night and it's like you're
completely unaffected I am like pretty
sensitive to caffeine but I really love
caffeine so I do I have like kind of
gauged this a little bit because I have
experienced I don't know if it was
actual caffeine intoxication but when
you were over caffeinated yeah it's like
a really horrible feeling so I did 1200
milligrams leads to caffeine
intoxication and I guess that isn't even
necessarily over a certain period of
time or whatever or also known as the
gigantic Red Bull the one that looks
like a forty twelve hundred if you drink
that your caffeine intoxicated because
you should not be Red Bulls that like
you need two hands no it's pretty
intense
its enormous so yeah for me it looks
like a [ __ ] forty it just encourage
you it encourages you to binge drink
caffeine those things yeah like they
should just sell funnels with it like
three in the top so that you just open
your throat yeah or it's like a can that
has like the shotgun presort listen to
it it has like a tab at the bottom that
you just break off and shot it open your
throat um well I'd like to first say um
I have a hundred percent drinking that
much yeah you had that much today
probably sad okay so how much caffeine
does it take to be technically
intoxicated by caffeine 40 milligrams
per ounce of pee you peed that day oh my
god that way it's relative to body
weight sort of or pee weight pee way I
think pee way is a more accurate
measurement of someone's what I have no
idea where I was going with that
someone's lying yeah basically just have
to measure how much PEP that day and
then somehow factor in your milligrams
of caffeine but I don't know if you
measure the caffeine before you like pee
or Julia's done with it I'm done that's
my
would you like to know yet what it is
yeah wait can I give you like a serious
guess this isn't for the game Jeff okay
1,700 no crimes okay okay recent
consumption of caffeine usually in
excess of 250 milligrams more than to
more than two to three cups of brewed
coffee Wow okay ready
you must exhibit five or more of the
following signs developing during or
shortly after caffeine use restlessness
nervousness excitement insomnia flushed
face [ __ ] go so all of the reasons
that one would drink caillou yeah that
sounds like my Monday morning that's
what I'm saying
according god so we get a tortillas
every single day you could get diagnosed
with caffeine the little cage the little
energy shots we take have more than that
daily 250 250 no it doesn't say ah I've
looked really add cuz it's in a blend it
doesn't tell you but I've looked online
there's like three or 400 in that one
there's like three cuz that's the extra
strength yeah nicholae intoxication
technically intoxicated from one little
energy shot or is that like three four
ounces three ounces Jesus what that is
nuts
alright well um so I got a problem and
it's doing it's funny there's no like
there's a you know alcohol dependency
and cannabis and all of this but there's
no there's caffeine intoxication there's
no caffeine addiction yeah
which seems backwards because I feel
like there's plenty of people there God
to cap caffeine addiction is a real
thing it's a real I mean I don't know I
guess that there's not like a specific
mental disorder for caffeine addiction
but it is an addictive drug because it
changes the way your body your body
chemistry works completely so right well
and if you're like if you're like us and
you start your day with caffeine and
drink it throughout the day and then one
day you just stop
it's awful like because your body is
used to those you like fulfilled without
side
get really bad headaches you feel
exhausted you feel like I'm yeah I am
was like depression it's bad it's
actually really bad like I think like a
year and a half ago when we first
starting out I would drink a lot of
caffeine with you like - we drink
together we go to get coffee we'd have
little energy shots we'd have whatever
and I remember it got to a point where I
was like getting a little worried
because I had never triggered this much
caffeine so what I did was and at the
time I was taking beta alanine as a
supplement by itself for workouts
because it's good for muscle recovery
and it just it I liked it so it helps
and that stuff if you don't know it's
also in pre-workout mix so it gives you
that to sort of like itchy tingling
feeling in your face in your arms and
your body it's like a kind of a flushing
feeling sort of like a nice and flush
but it's more like needle II yeah
sometimes it makes your face it makes
your face really itchy it's like if you
take well that's why I don't drink
5-hour energies because it makes me
really it was nice and in that I think
that's what you're experiencing but yeah
anyway so I would regularly take sorry
this is a complete Angela I would
regularly take beta alanine and caffeine
before I worked out and so when I got to
this point I was like getting scared
that I was taking too much caffeine what
I did was I went cold turkey no caffeine
for like a week and for the workouts I
just increased my dosage of beta alanine
to try to trick my body into thinking I
was caffeinated because I was still
getting the tingly feeling and it didn't
like didn't work that bad like I thought
I'd kind of like if I were to go cold
turkey now and try to work out for a
week I would be miserable and my
strength would be down and my energy
would be down but um that was definitely
like an interesting little experiment I
did I mean it wasn't hanging dangerous
levels of beta alanine I just increased
a little bit right but yeah caffeine is
a it's definitely hard to replace yeah
I'm not really the type of person that
gives a [ __ ] about cycling off of
caffeine just gimme well I'll tell you
one thing is like the moment I drink
caffeine after that week I had half of
what I would normally do and I was
off-the-wall it resets like that it's
crazy yeah I have been trying to get my
caffeine more organically lately because
I it was getting to the point where I
was drinking like Red Bull multiple Red
Bulls a day so what's an organic like
coffee so like coffee or tea
um just because I don't know you know
you're just thought out the yeah this
[ __ ] yeah all the other stuff but if
some of its like nasty well and you know
it's really interesting to like if I
start my day with a coffee and then I
like don't really eat anything or
whatever by the end of the day I'm
feeling like absolute [ __ ] but if I
start my day with a Red Bull or an
energy drink or something like that and
I don't really eat throughout the day by
the end of the day I'm feeling fine like
it's crazy how caffeine metabolizes
everything that you've like consumed
there and then when you're actually
taking an energy drink that has the sort
of vitamins and minerals and stuff in it
like it does give you a pledge yeah
better yeah um more of a well-rounded
yeah yeah when I worked at the tanning
salon a billion [ __ ] years ago
we had like smart waters and like
Monster energy drinks and so you could
like buy it and then put your money in
the [ __ ] cash sure sure just go get
him so you know I'm [ __ ] spend a lot
of my money I stay awake at work yeah
and I was doing the same thing you know
I'm like dirt poor but if I bought it
from the tanning salon it was so much
cheaper than 7-eleven for some reason
because nobody really wants to [ __ ]
buy them I swear we had them in stock
just like for us yeah sorry um so I was
drinking like a ton of monster and
that's really how I started drinking
like Red Bulls and Red Bull vodka and
all that when it was like my choice like
a 1 and I was like I'll drink a Red Bull
vodka yeah and I was drinking like a lot
of like the carbonated energy drinks and
my teeth were killing me like my teeth
hurt so bad yeah and I went to the
dentist and I think it had only been
like 3 months that I've been working
there drinking like a monster or a half
or monster or two at work a day over the
day yeah and she's like are you drinking
a lot of energy energy drinks and I'm
like well yeah isn't everybody yeah you
know in 2014 8 or 9 or whatever like
monster and rebel we're on like a huge
upswing you know they're huge
and I was like well doesn't everybody
that's all that's our choice right
you hear that and she was like yeah your
teeth look [ __ ] I'm like [ __ ] so what
was it in the energy drinks this is a
combination of the sugar and the
carbonation like it'd be the same if I
chug - [ __ ] yeah yeah that makes sense
that's pretty crazy though because you
don't think about that when you're
having energy drinks I honestly don't
even view them as the same as like soda
I know but they kind of arms yeah even
the sugar-free wonder yeah because those
chemicals will do the same thing or
worse to your teeth public yeah I mean I
don't know but I'm just I would
speculate that that's wild isn't it yeah
they hurt so bad hurt us
was it that weird tingly although news
for anyone or like hope for anyone that
was in that situation or is currently in
that situation yeah um if you just stop
and then you just take care of your
teeth and it goes away yeah Joe that's
good listen to your teeth listen to your
teeth be your teeth love you too alright
the last one last one okay let's finish
this up bra tourism will you spell it f
r o TT e u R is M rider ISM key you are
go first FRA tourism when a person
rushes a fraternity and when they ask
them to dress up for an event they come
because they can't help it they come
dressed as Harry Potter or in his mind
Harry fraud er oh my god
go you're welcome
FRA tourism dick sword-fighting
oh I knew there was a name for that
that's what it's called some nice
playful Pro tourism oh my god let me
post earier like Craigslist ad like
looking for someone interested in FRA
tourism and for EM because no cop is
gonna read Brett's DSM and row that FRA
tourism Wow
those are some good answers yes by the
way if you're in edges I'm gonna give
both of you points I guess technically
that means that Julian one who owned the
caffeine one though Oh cuz well who was
closest well I said 40 milligram per
ounce of pee okay Julian I read said
1200 I said 1,200 so Brett was closest
well how do you know even though I was
like a thousand oh I think you said we
just a tie you said you're serious
answer was 1,700 oh you're right that so
we taught it mean that we tied always
read I have to pick no no we tied total
three to three oh we should I think
overall I damn it should we do one live
like off the like off our cuff yeah
tiebreaker I'll just I'll just look up a
word okay yeah bright now we'll just
chat ladies okay Bo hold on ya know what
I didn't tell you what it was oh god
raise the process yeah but you gave him
the point her you gave me the point
honey he's got a point for it I got a
wheelchair point yeah sorry I'm off the
walls okay for fraud or is it because
you're intoxicated so in talking I mean
I don't carry fraud her I'm gonna say to
an intervention mofo closes you would
intervention I drink more I actually
need it yeah broader ISM is over a
period of at least six months
recurrent intense sexually arousing
fantasies sexual urges or behaviors
involving touching and rubbing against
non consent okay he was so close that's
insanely that's what I'm saying like
brett has gotten like the gist of what
these things could be that's literally
wait your definition
kind of falls under that umbrella it
does so it's bit well it's basically
like uh you want to rub up against
people in public that don't know who you
are
that's Rotter ism that's basically
sword-fighting for that I was up
sensually speak well unless I'm a little
scared how close you got that was pretty
cool
yeah but retro dick sword-fighting still
really close all right all right you
guys discuss that and I will look up a
difficult word and then you guys have to
give me your definitions okay for the
tie for the win I will say that I have
the the dictionary app on my phone and I
do look at the word of the day every day
sure do yeah cuz I don't know I like
words yeah I need honestly like I need
to get back to reading when I read a lot
I was like in that thing about serene a
lot and I would learn so many [ __ ]
words and I couldn't even help it
because I would read a word that I
didn't know and I was not going to keep
reading unless I looked it up and I was
like okay now I get what's happening but
it's just like it's kind of contagious
like you know anything like you read and
you're like oh I'm learning words but
I'm enjoying more of the book now it's
kind of you want to do both more I need
to get back in it I miss that I also
enjoy the two thoris the fourth this is
the thorah the really fun when I was
writing for the newspaper for Chapman
the Panther shout-out to the Panther I
was a sports editor for a while and when
you write you're writing stories every
week like lots of stories yeah and you
can't use these offices yeah especially
when you were a sports reporter you know
like they came out on top you have to
find like 50 different ways to say that
or they lost or you don't even like yeah
or injured you know I mean so you know
obviously the bare bones were to keep
but yeah use that thing a lot that thing
is super helpful I love that the source
the source
all right the song is the one who do
source yeah here we often he's got it
yeah I mean you get you if you want time
to write it you can or if you want to
just do it alive then do it I say we
just like okay we'll do a lot alright
wait then can I do some cuz I like
making up silly definitions you
whose do one from wherever you want
all right you ready okay so just a word
hocus I'm gonna lose it
yeah okay if you have to be honest if
you know what this is then say it so
that we can't okay
pettifog er oh I don't know what that is
petty fogger yes definition he overs or
should I go first how much time do we
have to come up with this do we just go
would you like to me to spell it yes
spell it pe t TI f OG ger okay I'm going
you give us the part of speech seems
like that guy's a pedi fogger okay so
petty fodder when a person can't resist
but going around and petting other
people's animals getting so choked up by
emotions that their eyes fog up that's
petty petty fogger it what are you gonna
beat that with um cuz you're petting and
petty sorry I think petty fogger means
seriously petty fogger is um when you
walk into a walk-in freezer there's like
you know how sometimes they'll be like
kind of vapour in the air
that's pettifog er that's sick
that's really good god I swear Brett's
like got his own di7 his mine I just
asked her to use it in a sentence though
it's not it's okay petty fogger is a
person who tries to befuddle others with
his speech Oh like he tries to outsmart
people by saying big words Oh the
pettifog that's guy who wears like a
monocle right he walks around like the
Balinese okay that's a good one
um so that's the tiebreaker so I think
Julian run yeah
with is here you're so emotionally
charged by petting other people's
animals that you just hurry up and cry
very very creative well thank you um
Jenna do we want you to guess one out
yeah look up a word on your phone so
just a word great you're doing that you
want it yeah alright Brett's on it
Brett's looking up a word on his own so
this is basically just dictionary right
no no um but we could do a couple of you
on with you anymore you you moderated
our game we should moderate I didn't get
to do anything okay
yeah sad also if you guys like ooooh I
have one huh alright we got are you
ready oh sorry I don't know interrupt I
was just gonna say if you guys have
friends and need a game to play or even
a drinking game you could play
dictionary it's really fun it's really
fun especially if you have funny friends
which I trust that you do go your word
is the lassic þ à la SS I see ok so
we'll give you a seconds Vlasic wait
with a V or a th th a ok la SS I see ok
do you want a couple seconds we let your
nerves you have to come up with an - oh
we're all doing it alright nobody knows
yeah got it sorry hi I'm slow today um
okay I have one all right you go first
Hey ok
the lassic is a theme park built for
this little kid named Theo who was a big
fan of Jurassic Park but they've decided
to name it the the last and it's also a
period in time when Theo was the most
exciting dinosaur Theo ever that's a
great one the Thalassa k-- is cute
Thanks oh good death go down good death
who go to do definition whatever your
turn fully okay
the lassic is when a guy goes around
trying to tell people he wants to get
surgery on his eyes but no one knows
what he's hardened because he's
pronouncing it wrong yes that's so gay
okay you and you what um Vlasic of or
pertaining to seas and oceans whoa okay
all right
feel like I should have known that or or
of or pertaining to smaller bodies of
water as C's and gulfs as distinguished
from larger oceanic us bodies damn yeah
that's I didn't know that that's weird I
feel like I should have known that too
your hair is kind of the lassic it is oh
look at this little de lassic hair you
guys want to wear um why don't I give
you guys wood okay yeah cuz I haven't
moderated yet I've already read all of
those loads okay
mMmmm good petty bogging I've already
ran all alone oh um do you know what
widdershins is whitter shin widdershins
how do you say all right WI WI DD er Shi
ns widdershins witters okay um I did not
read wish it didn't all right whoever's
ready first can go first okay
widdershins are like someone who has
really really really short
knee to ankle love life length leg they
have widowed shins so good widowed shins
that's good Bret top it well where was
she
we win whittled Asians um so I was kind
of along the same lines but I was
thinking it like when kids are playing
soccer and they're chasing the ball and
then like they to kids like kick each
other that action is called wiedersehen
there they did it wither
widdershins
Oh God those are mostly sorry point for
you both
Ramsey style we should have done this
whole podcast just these yeah I know we
can start over whatever you want
do you wanna heal I don't mean this is
way fun here you want to start the
podcast over no I guess not
you can do it another time what's just
so much sillier it is so much sillier
but I feel like we had a great [ __ ]
game
yeah well okay and I already tried
another like category that I want to do
in the future
cuz I know that there are some silly-ass
tools out there like oh yes like oh yeah
what actual do we should do that like
another time too so we could spread the
love in the other poke yeah I may give
you another I got to read you this
definition guys right widdershins
widdershins in a contrary or
counterclockwise direction what boo I
think it's when kids kick each other in
the shins with kids all right Brett won
that one I I'm the judge
yes all right
did you read I didn't read any of us
except for wait wait you want to go yeah
I'll go tells me and Jen again yeah Oh
game on
I Love New York ooh all right
verb iteration it's ve RBI ger a tion
verb iteration whoa ah forbid raishin is
when you like to plant things in a
garden and make food but you only can do
it by swearing at it and telling it to
do verbs kick punch jump [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then it grows your garden oh
that's good I love that [ __ ] forbid you
just abuse it and it grows yes verbally
verbally region let's get one the
farming of using verbal abuse good
mm-hmm
where do we get that garden all right
mine is forbidden when instead of food
you put written pieces of paper with
verbs on them in the fridge so they get
verb iterated so the reason that I chose
this one is because it kind of crosses
over between both games that we've
played tonight verba duration is the
constant or obsessive repetition of
meaningless words or phrases that would
be a good friend Ave that's ridiculous
we all know someone that a syringe yo
door they're like your bid duration or
something
yeah that's your deal is it is your
friend verb iterated wait how is it too
far wrong I roam you guys want one for
for a bibliophile booyah all right so
when a person is irrationally and
deathly afraid of not a bib not a
leotard but a bib and a leotard at the
same time Biblio phobia Biblio phobia
Wow
I mean my my immediate guests just based
off of the word is like fear of books
yeah it's kind of a book it's the fear
of running out of reading material
that's such a fun I'm not laughing at it
it just isn't wow that's like a very
deep-rooted like yeah what if I read all
the things well that's got to be cause
I'm out well I feel like that sort of
thing I don't know anything about
anything but I feel my guess is that
that sort of thing is caused by an
upbringing where their sole source of
entertainment was reading maybe you're
saying that kids that tweet 800 times a
day don't have a biblia phobia
that's a twiddly or phobia yeah that's
different
what if no one's tweeting anything what
are we gonna read tumblr come on
what duh myspace yeah dig up everyone's
MySpace all right Jenna hold up the W
like this Brad you hold up the T what
yeah this was a fun podcast though would
you definitely play the dictionary I
might the idea of coming on here and
playing a game like that because it's
fun because we're absolutely just like
[ __ ] around and also I like the the
pre-emptive ones where we kind of plan
our answers because those can be funny
it's [ __ ] around but it's creative
like yeah absolutely
yeah yeah well thank thanks for joining
us Pratt this was fun yeah thanks for
having realized your answers Brett was a
lot of fun on the podcast link Brett in
the description we love you want to
follow him on social if you guys have a
Twitter phobia you need to see tweets he
tweets pretty well but all right we'll
be back next week for another podcast
thank you so much for watch I think next
week is a big number 20 is it yep
because this is 19 yet thank you guys
for watching us and listening and thanks
for getting us all the way to put it in
the best of 2014 I too
people huge yes so cool well you know
what we've just always been
unprofessional and shitty since day one
how we gonna remain it's just it means a
lot that you guys appreciate the the
substance and whatever that we're doing
rather than how shitty it is absolutely
the fact that you guys have listened and
cared this much means that you really do
just care about like I said what we're
talking about which is cool thank you
there's no funny business but anyway we
love you we'll see you next week have a
good week